Beyonce drops her new music video  formation just one day before taking the  Superbowl stage with Coldplay you know  you damn [ __ ] when you comes out this  conversation  without any warning again Beyonce  released a hot new single Saturday  exclusively on title and it's taking us  all back to her Southern roots better  Alabama Louisiana you mix that Negro  with that Creole make the Texas battle a  source confirms to ET that Beyonce will  perform her new release during the Pepsi  Super Bowl halftime show this music  video shot in New Orleans Louisiana is  giving us life these daughter Blue Ivy  makes a surprise cameo and the flawless  singer seemingly has a message for  everyone who criticized the four year  old pair of ears continues to play with  these new dance moves let's just hope  this time bee doesn't blow out the  stadium lights the power went out after